the Joe Rogan experience
dealt these dogs at your training you
know Phoebe was like that was very
interesting listening to how effective
using Belgian Malinois is that we're
using yeah primarily our main dogs a
Belgian male and you know are powerful
dogs they are amazed they're so smart
yes in their eyes no way you can see it
right and like hey man how you doing
yeah yeah they're not like looking at a
poodle no they're not like looking at
our labs not that sweet little face hang
out yeah yeah the thing that's that's
cool about these dogs and um and I can't
talk enough about it man because no
matter where you said everybody loves a
good dog story and you know some people
say well dual-purpose you're gonna bite
guys what's with that is a you know
really aggressive and when you look at
it's a lifesaver for everybody it's a
lifesaver for us it's a lifesaver for
the suspect too because it usually
involves a potential gunfight that the
dog basically you know alleviated
because she or he was there so we got
our canine program in agency going kind
of full speed around 2008 ish I mean at
three we have three levels of canine we
have like the companion ride-along
canine that kind of does everything with
yeah she's never gonna buy to anybody
and that's Apollo that's like my lab
right and then we have the detection
level dog and most looser Labradors like
marshall like Apollo because labs have
such amazing noses they really can hold
on scent you know they can trained to
detect many sense and we certify them in
different things and then there's the
Phebe's you know the belgian males or
the shepherds and really it's become
mostly males now in our agency and my
mouth um they just do better in the heat
you know shepherds are longer haired and
we're in hundred degree weather we're on
long hikes you know or unsupported those
dogs might have to sit quietly after
hiking eight miles and sit in a prone
quietly while we're watching and
observing and stocking it on suspects to
make an apprehension and arrest safely
and hopefully avoid a gunfight so and
we've also found with the with the males
they like I said they just hold up
better on average and there's certainly
exceptions to that but when we got our
dual purpose program back on track these
are dogs that will bite when they need
to on command but they have great noses
so they'll still detect wonderfully you
know
finding evidence finding tainted weed
whatever the case may be a firearm a
bear gall bladder all of that but
they'll also you know like Phoebe was
nicknamed the fur missile because when
it was time for her to go to work and
some guy was going to pull a weapon on
us she was all business and a cool thing
about a dog like her and and Mike
Ritland I got into this on his show
especially and he was blown away he said
I've never heard of a dog in a domestic
law enforcement team that's had like she
had 116 apprehension bites in her career
and she had hundred and sixteen no joke
joke sixteen cartel guys out there
telling stories about this dog yeah
they're saying no more pair of I've been
bit too many times no but the cool thing
about that was the standpoint of life
she saved and she also arrests another
eight to nine hundred that she didn't
have to buy it in her career that's a
lot how many have you guys arrested when
I retired we were over a thousand Wow in
in five and a half years yeah and we and
against all these all grow-ops
all grow-ups yeah these are all grow ops
are related to grow up so that these are
all guys that are armed all guys that
have knives or guns you know that you're
not getting bit unless you know you're a
deadly force threat on some level or a
significant threat so uh yeah it's been
a lot of guys so that number that you're
talking about ten thousand that really
is conservative very I think it's very
much so yeah that is so insane because
if you fly over like Humboldt or any any
of these areas particularly medicine Oh
Northern California yeah the density of
the forest and the the public land out
there yeah there's a lot of land there's
a lot of land and a lot of you know
potential we're not seeing so and that's
still still thriving so when you you
know when you when you look at Phoebe as
a canine and you go well let's see she
was in the field doing these type
operations for about seven or eight
years and yeah that's great from a
record standpoint and numbers and the
life she saved but it gives you like a
like a snapshot of the issue how many
you guys did we not catch that were out
there armed right that we weren't
involved in you know we weren't involved
so and the dogs of just save lives man
they have saved Phoebe I go into this in
the new book especially in 2012 but
right before our team started Phoebe
saved my life Brian's
life and all these other operators in
Santa Clara County in Silicon Valley
right where I grew up because she
engaged a guy that was pulling a Russian
automatic pistol on me and I was the
support for the for Brian I was
basically his k-9 handler or support guy
and Brian had to deal with this other
growers partner that had a big tourist
judge revolver on his hip and he was
pulling it so he goes for that guy and
says John just take my dog and Phoebe's
occupy eight and he's biting this guy in
the calf and you know this guy's nose
down and we don't know he's got this
weapon and I start to see it coming out
and I get on him and I do what I need to
do with some physical control and some
strikes and whatnot to get the gun out
of his hand but had she not been on that
guy on a bite show that guns turned on
me at five feet I'm engaged all the
rifleman behind me I'm you know I'm in a
gunfight again we've been in too many of
those already
how many gunfights do Beth our team's
been in six and I and I've been on the
ground for four out of the six that her
guys have been involved in and they've
all been around this particular problem
we had a lot less once the team got
formalized and so we started using dogs
but we still had two during the window
of the team being operational that we
couldn't avoid and dogs played a big
part in that as I go into many stories
so
[Applause]